y ahora
[Música]
en la vida todos cometemos errores y
siempre nos dicen aprendan de ellos y
nunca nos dicen como mi error más grande
casi me quita la vida todo empezó por mi
gran admiración a los militares
desde niño siempre me gustaba asistir a
los desfiles militares ver cada 29 de
julio la gran parada militar ver esa
pasión ese respeto ese orden esa mística
del comando en cada uno de ellos
en mi provincia no se ha escuchado en
mucho el tema del terrorismo pero sí en
las partes alejadas y mucho más en el
departamento de ayacucho y sus distritos
donde nace en mí ese patriotismo y esas
ganas de querer defender a mi país como
militar
desde niño siempre me gustaron las
películas de acción de guerra
patriotismo incluso ya me imaginaba
peleando contra ellos contra los
terroristas ganando los incluso morir
por mi patria si así lo fuese a los 16
años entre el servicio militar
para sentir y saber que era ese soldado
culminó mi periodo de dos años y me
engancho en el batallón contraterrorista
alto con vaina número 79
llevo cursos militares y finalmente el
curso alfa un curso antiterroristas
donde uno aprenda manipular todo tipo de
armas colectivas te enseñan el trabajo
de patrullaje en selva operaciones en
selva
y todo iba perfecto
en este curso cuando uno ingresa pierde
el grado y el nombre solamente lleva lo
que es un polo y con su número y el mío
era el número 38 tal y cual una camiseta
de fútbol desde lo lejos se
identificaban y te llamaban por tu
número
y unos días antes de finalizar el curso
se lleva a cabo las elecciones internas
donde me entero que estaba nominado a
salir entre los primeros pero todo no
salió como lo previsto
esta noche cometí el error más grande de
mi vida
recuerdo muy bien era una noche de junio
del año 2005
37 estábamos en la selva de pasco viento
y número 37
no quería aprenderla y me lo da a mí
en ese momento yo era el encargado de la
patrulla de jaguar 2 quería que la
misión salve tal y cual se me había
encomendado
era una dinamita de 15 centímetros un
fulminante y una mecha lenta
eran las 2 y 59 de la madrugada
incursión de la misión prendo la mecha y
tengo mi objetivo ya controlado en ese
momento que decidió avanzar ya mi
objetivo decidió aguantar
en ese momento mientras la mecha se va
acortando lentamente me confié mucho
y ya decido ir y en ese momento que
pienso a querer hacer la detonación de
un impacto muy fuerte
en ese momento mis oídos ensordecieron
recuerdo dos puntos
donde empiezo a agarrar mi cara y veo mi
mano ensangrentada
y el otro es cuando volteó la cabeza a
la derecha y veo que ya no tiene una
mano
en ese momento mis compañeros dicen que
me empecé a desesperar otros dicen que
me desmayé
porque no era un enfrentamiento no era
una emboscada
lo que era era un entrenamiento de
equipo
ven que ahora me sigo equivocando aquí
en text contando mi propia historia
imagínense que todos estos dolores
físicos
que tenía ese momento de la pérdida de
mi mano mi cara ensangrentada con el ojo
que no podía ver no tenía ningún punto
de comparación al momento que llegué al
hospital de oxapampa cuando la enfermera
impertodo empezó a cortar mi pelo de
militar ese pueblo que me identificaba
del número 38 en ese momento sentí el
final de mi vida como militar mi sueño
de ser comando de las fuerzas especiales
habían terminado el sueño de defender a
mi patria también
ya en camino al hospital de oxapampa
luego al de la merced imagínense qué era
lo que se me pasaba en ese momento por
la cabeza alguien que acaba de perder
una mano
en ese momento ya me imaginaba como un
pirata del caribe
sin con un parche en el ojo con un
garfio
empezar a imaginar que me digas cómo iba
a ser mi vida de hoy para adelante cómo
me miraría así incluso qué tipo de
apoyos me pondrían
empezar a imaginar cómo iba a ser mi
vida de hoy para adelante cómo iba a
empezar demás amarrarme las zapatillas
cómo iba a ser
mis necesidades
incluso como iba a ir a nadar
me encantaba nadar
en ese momento que llevó al hospital
hospital militar
entre en un estado de hecho pensamientos
negativos incluso quise quitarme la vida
me miré al espejo
mira una cara quemada sin una mano
empecé a llorar
y en ese momento entraron dos amigos
míos uno que no tenía dos piernas y el
otro ciego
me ven llorando y me dicen qué pasa
vas a llorar por esa cosa
muy mal comando mira - a nosotros sin
piernas ciego disfrutamos la vida hoy en
día fue ese momento que ellos me
levantaron esa moral esa moral que lo
tenía derrotado en esos momentos en ese
momento dije aquí se acaba todo
empezó mi tratamientos mi rehabilitación
pero de una buena actitud
empezó la terapia ocupacional porque yo
era diestro en ese momento ahora soy
zurdo
en ese momento tengo unos anécdotas
impresionantes que hoy en día
lo recuerdo y les cuento
eran las nueve de la mañana me tocaba la
terapia ocupacional donde me enseñaron a
escribir con la mano izquierda en ese
momento que agarro mi cuaderno agarro mi
lapicero y empiezo
a meter un pique para poder llegar se me
cae el lapicero y en ese momento intentó
recogerlo rápido y me acuerdo que ya no
tenía una mano en ese momento me reí de
mí mismo
y ahí
una fecha ya durmiendo me empieza a
aplicar el cuello
y saben lo que dicen intente rascar más
agarre en pleno sueño y no llegaba
abro los ojos y veo que ya no tiene una
mano
salgo del hospital militar me dan de
alta me dan una prótesis las cuales
logro usado cinco veces hoy en día
'no así no uso prótesis y me siento
feliz
a pesar de mi superación cuando los
errores no se trabajan estos vuelven a
aparecer
ya en la vida civil
empecé a hacer negocios
que no me salía muy bien me dediqué lo
que es al alcohol a las fiestas
ah y de viajes
en ese momento vive una vida loca
al pasar el tiempo decidí cambiar decidí
emprender otro negocio donde saqué un
préstamo de 18.000 dólares del banco y
me compré un carro cero kilómetros
parecía que todo iba a cambiar
pero no fue así un día
de fiesta de salida con el carro
empiezo a creerme un piloto
uno de los buenos decidió manejar ebrio
pero ese momento sabes lo que pasó
estrella de mi carro lo estrelló contra
un poste y casi pierde la vida en ese
momento sentí el dolor más grande como
mi primera vez
pero bueno al pasar el tiempo
vuelvo a lo mismo otra vuelta de alcohol
a las fiestas pero llegó un momento en
mí donde dije que esto debería cambiar
y como al final de un túnel siempre hay
una luz
y siempre y alguien en tu vida quien te
hace cambiar de todas maneras una vez
que visiten al general me encuentro con
un amigo
el capitán carlos felipe a córdoba un
par atleta donde me dice
hermano hoy en día nosotros no podemos
defender a nuestra patria en el campo de
batalla pero si lo podemos defender en
el campo del deporte te invito a que
practiques el para deporte para que le
digo yo
es un deporte adaptado para personas con
discapacidad excelente nosotros no lo
defendemos no lo podemos defender a la
parte en el campo de batalla pero sí en
el campo de deporte fenomenal dije yo
mismo soy
empecé con el parate y con no soy
seleccionado nacional hoy en día
practicó este deporte tres años tengo
viajes que ni siquiera pensaba
llegar a esos países conozco italia
tokio turquía brasil estados unidos
fueron campeonatos donde fui a
participar el primer campeonato me tocó
costa rica- llevaba dos meses de
entrenamiento mientras el otro ya tenía
siete años
pero como todo militar dentro de la
cancha no a la cancha no al campo de
batalla entre a un tatami a pelear y a
defender mi bandera en ese momento eran
tres asaltos los tres asaltos lo peleo
lo terminó peleando y saben que gano
el pues
y tenía más de experiencia pero lo que
yo tenía era mi moral
empecé a ver mis vídeos empecé a ver los
errores que había cometido como era
nuevo dije ni más de ahí posteriormente
seguir campamentos de entrenamiento
llega un año llegó a eeuu una
competencia contra un argentino en ese
momento ya seguía patea dominaba el pie
me movía porque en ese tiempo de costa
rica era tipo un robot
pero ahora sí más movimiento yo voy a
pelear con este argentino las cuales iba
ganando la pelea pero en el tercer
asalto me fractura la mano la única que
tenía pero seguí peleando
seguir peleando porque tenía esa moral
bien alta y perdí por tres puntos era un
campeón para panamericana este muchacho
perdido por tres puntos y dije que la
revancha sería que en lima
y fue así disfrute de la medalla de
bronce aquí en prima en estos juegos
parapanamericanos
dónde
el que ganó fui yo y fue por diferencia
porque porque la casa se respetaba y
estaba en mi país donde yo tenía que
darlo todo por mí por mi patria y por mi
bandera gane esta pelea
y ahí terminé la pelea
vivir la vida
feliz
disfrute el triunfo me vinieron buenas
cosas incluso hoy en día soy el número
14 en el ranking mundial de este deporte
ya que los otros practican este para
deporte diez años quince años yo recibió
tres años hoy en día tengo una meta y un
sueño de clasificar a estas olimpiadas
de estas para olimpiadas que van a ser
en tokio 2020
hoy me sigo equivocando y lo seguiré
haciendo
como todos pero aprendido a trabajar
estos errores así como yo los trabajo en
un tatami peleando
y hoy en día ustedes también lo pueden
trabajar
y dime tú cómo superaste es
el último error que cometiste
gracias
[Aplausos]